Stellt sich raus, ist ein Eingang fälliger, fälliger, auf die Reine, es wurde Jazz hier, die und zwar eine fucking Jazzbade.
Der Till hat eine fucking Trompete auf dem Kopf, auf dem Kopf drauf. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast UFOs.
Jorin Wim Will und Stefan Tietze, wir freuen uns sehr, dass ihr hier reingeschneit seid. Setzt euch hin, zieht die Jacken aus, zieht die Schlüpper. Hoch. Schlüpper wieder hoch, zieht die Hosen richtig hoch, manchmal hängen die zu tief. Ich sage immer, lieber Schlüpper und Hose richtig hoch, dann kommt ihr gut durch den Tag.
Auf jeden Fall. Mein Schlöpper ist offen, ich sag's dir gleich. Mein Schlappenschlöpper ist offen. Ich hab mir gerade einen Döner reingepfeffert und ich bin völlig am Ende. Ich möchte ehrlich mit euch sein, diese Folge wird keine angenehme für mich, denn mein Körper, mein Köter, mein Köter ist komplett im Standby-Modus, ist im Ruhemodus, der ist runtergefahren, der Döner muss verdaut werden. Der Döner muss verdaut werden. Der Döner muss verdaut werden. Ich bin halb Mensch, halb Döner aktuell, ich bin Möhner und ich übernehme keine Verantwortung über alles, was ich sage in dieser Folge. Musst du die ganze Zeit so nervig aufstoßen, so eklig? Oh ja, so ein richtiges ... Der Döner spricht aus mir. Ich bin halb Mensch, halb Knoblauch. Ich habe den ganzen Döner gegessen, mit allem. Ich habe die Zwiebeln gegessen, Salat gegessen, ich habe nichts übrig gelassen. Und ich habe den ganzen Döner gegessen, nicht wie sonst. Man teilt sich das ein, erst ein Drittel, dann Nachmittag vielleicht nochmal das zweite Drittel, dann im Kühlschrank zu Hause. Nachmittags. Nein, ich habe ihn komplett verzerrt und ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe mich dabei selber ein bisschen verzerrt. Ich habe mich selbst in mich reingegessen. Da unterscheiden wir uns, weil ich erst so viel, mir reicht kein einzelner Döner. Das führte für mich höchstens ein Snack, keine Mahlzeit. Vor allem, ich finde Döner … Anderthalb Döner sind meine, meistens generell bei allen Gerichten, ich brauche anderthalb, dann bin ich happy. Ja, okay, verstehe ich. Oder Vorspeise, Hauptspeise. Deswegen immer, ich packe mir noch was beim Bäcker ein. Das Problem beim Döner ist, dass durch diese, durch dieses, der Sand der Zeit rinnt durch meine Finger, so es fällt alles auseinander. Ja. beesse ich den so schnell auf, aus Angst, dass ich wasliere, und ich bin während dem Essen null auf Genuss gepolt, sondern auf, okay, hier links habe ich was, okay, rechts sehe ich schon, da kommt die Tomate raus, Achtung, jetzt mal links, aber nichts, und dann kommt von rechts so ein Passant und macht so, ach, ach, ach, ach, ach, ach, und rechts, okay, und ich habe im Kopf schon wie so eine strategische, wie so eine Napoleon-Map, ich weiß, okay, meine Infanterie ist hier rechts, die hält die Tomaten zurück, links allerdings habe ich die Alufolie noch, die hält die Zaziki im Griff. Wie in dem Film Napoleon. Aber sie kommen von rechts.
Le droit.
Sie kommen von rechts. Oh nein, die Zaziki-Sosse kommt von rechts. Und das war wirklich das krasseste. Holy shit, Napoleon war so cool, weil er ist der erste Mensch, der auf die Idee kam, dass man nicht von vorne kommt, sondern auch vielleicht von rechts. Und wenn ich euch jetzt noch sage, dass ihr auch von links kommen könntet, dann platzen euch eure französischen Hirne weg. Das hat ein bisschen Hitler gedauert, bis man das verstanden hat. kam dann von links Alexander der Grosse vorne, Napoleon rechts, Hitler links, und dann ist vorbei und dann von schräg rechts. Leute, das kann es doch nicht gewesen sein. Also, ich hatte auf jeden Fall das Zangenmanöver, Tzatziki im Griff, das Fleisch kam mir von vorne entgegen und ich war so drin im Taktieren, dass ich überhaupt nicht mitbekommen habe, dass ich währenddessen eine köstliche Fleischtasche verzerrt habe.
Und am Ende hast du das Ding im Magen liegen und denkst dir, was denn da passiert? Und jetzt bin ich völlig ausgeknipst quasi. Ich finde das ja so spannend, Menschen haben ja immer so leichte, kleine, mini Zwangsneurosen. Oft nichts Gefährliches, aber zum Beispiel habe ich das, wo wir gerade beim Thema Essen sind, viele haben das, wenn sie im Restaurant sind, kriegen einen Teller mit viel Essen, sie müssen immer alles auf der Gabel haben. Kenne ich zum Beispiel, das ist so eine Zwangneurose. Also von jedem Segment. Genau, also jeder, und das ist auch glaube ich nicht so schlecht, wenn man halt kosten will, wie gut es eigentlich ist, dieses Gericht vor dem Teller, also weil es in guten Restaurants zum Beispiel ist, wo man das wertschätzen sollte, dann ist es glaube ich auch cool, einzelne Zutaten probieren, alle zusammen, aber viele haben das, die ich kenne, man muss alles auf der Gabel haben, bei mir ist es eher so, ich will die Beilagen erst wegessen, um dann das Beste zum Schluss noch zu haben. Das fand ich aber irgendwann kindisch und jetzt mache ich so einen Mischmasch, aber ich habe trotzdem noch die meisten Sachen auf der Mitte. Eine Sekunde auf der nächsten einfach. Das ist eigentlich kindisch. Ich bin 14 geworden und genau an meinem Geburtstag habe ich gesagt, das ist zu kindisch. Jetzt bin ich ein Mann. Jetzt bin ich ein Mann, ich bin strafmündig und nun wird richtig gegessen. Also ich habe erst ein Drittel Pommes, zwei Drittel Pommes und am Ende habe ich noch, während ich das Meer über habe, das Hauptspeise habe ich noch ein bisschen Beilage übrig. Ja, ich habe diese weirde Zwangsnerose, dass ich keinen Bock habe, dass das komplette Essen über mich drüber fällt, während ich es esse. Genau. Sondern ich versuche es sozusagen in der Teigtasche drin zu halten, sodass es nicht komplett mir über die Hände rinnt und komplett rausfällt. Nee, das finde ich keine Zwangsnerose. Ich habe Angst, dass wenn meine Hände zu sehr mit Tzatziki-Sauce bedeckt sind, ich sie aus Versehen esse, weil ich sie sozusagen als Fleisch wahrnehme. Wenn sie so sehr in Tzatziki mit ein bisschen Schaf-Sauce getränkt sind, dann habe ich Angst, dass ich die Hände selbst in mich aufesse und dann aber den Knochen nicht kriege. Genau, ich kriege den Knochen nicht, also esse ich weiter, dann drehe ich mich einmal komplett auf links und dann ist der Döner wieder draußen. Ach, du Schander, hat zerkaut. Dann hast du dich selbst verdaut. Das ist das Problem. Was mir nämlich dann aufgefallen ist, weil es gibt ja auch diese gleiche Zwangsnerosen bei, zum Beispiel man isst Oreos. Oder man Amicelli zum Beispiel muss ich außen die Schokolade abessen und dann in der Mitte die Ader. Beim Amicelli? Moment, ist das denn stabil genug? Ist das nicht eine Creme-Füllung? Ja, ein bisschen. Achtung, da ist noch eine Keksschicht dazwischen, richtig. Und es ist nicht einfach. Moment, du kannst Schokolade vom Keks separieren beim Amicelli? Ja, und es ist nicht einfach und das versaut mir ein bisschen das Amicelli-Erlebnis. Ich bin ein großer Amicelli-Fan. An der Frequenz, wie du es erwähnst, merke ich das. Unsere grossen Snacks müssten wir mal, weil wir haben oft Kinder oder in kleinen Kategorien gedacht, was sind unsere Lieblingssnacks, aber unsere Lieblingssnacks bei Amicelli, ich kann noch nie meine Faszination für das Amicelli. Du erwähnst auch Giotto überdurchschnittlich viel. Mag ich auch gerne. Programmier doch mal eine KI, die einmal komplett alle Podcast-Ufo-Folgen anhört und dann macht ein Snack, Top-1-Snack, einfach mal wirklich objektiv. Wenn nicht jemand fragt, genau, nach Nennung, Snacks nach Nennung und dann haben wir die tatsächlichen objektiven Fakten, nicht dieses Larifari, ich erinnere mich falsch an Dublin-Bedöns. Oder ich will Leuten gefallen. Zum Beispiel, ich sage etwas bewusst irgendwie Nischiges, um Leuten zu gefallen, ah, das ist so ein spezieller Künstlertyp, dem gefällt das Amicelli, wohingegen ich will einfach nur dann die klaren Fakten, wovon rede ich will hier am meisten, das ist wahrscheinlich das Beste. Amicelli, Amicelli, Amicelli, Amicelli, Amicelli. So, aber was ich sagen wollte, es gibt nämlich diese Zwangsgründe noch bei anderen Dingen, zum Beispiel manche Männer, die ihre Haare mit Wachsstylen werden es kennen, man hat so eine Dose, die Strandmatte, und dann nimmt man da was raus. Und dann war ich mal bei einem Kumpel und ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es kam, vielleicht sind wir danach weggegangen oder sowas, jedenfalls haben wir beide, jedenfalls habe ich so eine Wachsdose aufgemacht. Und weil ich da drin gesehen habe, habe ich gedacht, muss ich den Kontakt beenden, ist es ein Soziopath? Nämlich diese Wachsdose war einmal, also er hat dann quasi immer, wie man das ja macht, von außen was genommen und dann hat er, und dann nimmt man irgendwas von der Mitte, und dann wird es halt gleichmässig weniger. Aber es bleibt flächenbündig. Bleibt eben, ja. Was er hatte, er ist immer außen rumgegangen, dass nur noch in der Dose ein riesengroßer Turm in der Mitte von Wachs war. Ich fand das fantastisch. Also super scary. Ich finde es fantastisch, um so einen Serienkiller in einem Film oder sowas zu etablieren. Wo niemand sagen kann, wir hätten es nicht gedacht, weil ab dem Punkt hast du deinen Kumpel immer als potenziellen Serienmörder im Gedächtnis und wenn die Nachrichten kommen, dann sagst du, ach so, Lukas? Ja, klar, natürlich. Das haben wir uns alle schon gedacht, ja. Ich war mal mit seiner Wachsdose und da waren Turme damit. Ach so, nee, klar. Hat niemand überrascht. Das war so ein Turm. Und das fand ich so weird, das war fast so ein Jumpscare-Moment.
Ja.
Weil es ist nichts Gefährliches per se, aber irgendwie sagt mir das aus, du bist so zwangsneurotisch, was diese eine Ansage, also hat er sonst nicht beobachtet bei ihm. Vor allem, ich würde interessieren, ob er ein Ritual hat, wie er dann diesen Turm zu Babel, dieses letzte Widerstandsnest, ob er das dann wegschmeisst, ob er das übrig bleibt oder ob er dann einmal im Monat so den ganzen Turm oder ob ihn von außen noch wegarbeitet. Also was ist da die Strategie, um da dem Herr zu werden? Das habe ich mich auch gefragt, da bin ich mal nachts da geblieben. Und zwar als am Boden nichts mehr war und nur noch der Turm massiv stand. Und ich habe genau diesen Moment abgepasst. Das war doch, weiß ich noch, eine Vollmondnacht. Dann stand ich da, ich habe gesagt, ciao, wir sehen uns dann, bis morgen. Ciao, mach's gut. Und dann bin ich rausgegangen, aber ich bin nicht gegangen. Ich habe mich in den Mülltonnen versteckt. Tür fiel ins Haus und dann habe ich gewartet, was passiert jetzt? Bin jetzt wieder hingelaufen, leise hingeschrieben, habe reingeguckt, was er macht. Bin sicher, dass er sich ein bisschen umgeguckt, hat noch so die Gläser, die wir hatten, gebraucht hatten, weggestellt und so. Dann war so, ja, geh ich ins Bett, diese typische, geh ich sagen, geh ins Bad und dann kam er direkt wieder raus, mit der Wachsdose in der Hand. So, und dann ist er rausgegangen, aus der Haustür muss ich mich verstecken, wieder hinter den Mülltonnen, und er ging mit der Wachstdose hinten in den Garten, ins Gartenhäuschen, wo ich noch nie drin war, nie drin war. Er hat mir gesagt, da ist auch nur so Gartengeräte drin und die waren so abgehangen, die Fenster, so schwarz. Dann geht er da rein, ich habe nicht genau gesehen, was er macht, ich bin hinter ihm und ich sehe nur, dass er das Ding rausmacht, diesen Turm rausmacht aus der ... Und er klebt das auf einen bestimmt zwei Meter zehn hohen Turm aus Strandmatte.
Klebt er das oben drauf.
Und ich habe nur diesen Turm gesehen, so im Halbdunkel ist der Mond schien rein, schon rein.
Ja.
Er dreht sich um und sieht mich, ich stehe da bleich er sagt das zu viel gesehen nein du baust einen turm aus strandmatte und er sagt ja schon seit ich ein kleiner junger das müssen ja schon unzählige das müssen ja unzählige Dosen gewesen sein die zu diesem Zum Turm führen. Ja, Turm. Unglaublich. Ein Turmbau zu Strandmatte. Wahnsinn.
Ja. Unglaublich, was Leute hinter verschlossenen Türen tun. Eklig. Jeder hat ein kleines Geheimnis. Widerlich. Aber ich bin ja froh, dass es so eine Art von Geheimnis ist. Dann weiss man, okay, es ist zumindest nichts Schlimmeres. Ja. So, du weisst ja, okay, es geht in die Richtung. Ja, ja, finde ich auch. Apropos, Menschen machen komische Dinge hinter verschlossenen Türen, eine mir nahestehende Person ist jetzt zur Schöffin gewählt worden und wurde jetzt unterwiesen. Und es ist irre, ich finde das so cool und ich will es unbedingt auch, nächste Wahlperiode erst hier in Köln zumindest, aber man muss 25 Jahre alt. Genau, genau. Und die Unterweisung stand an und dann war da ein Richter vom Schwurgericht und ein Staatsanwalt und dann wurden alle Schöffinnen und Schöffen des nächsten Wahljahres, also 24 bis 28, unterwiesen. Worum geht's, was darf man machen, was darf man nicht machen? Bis 28, also vier Jahre lang ist eine Schöffenschicht.
Man ist vier Jahre Schöffel und so maximal heisst es eigentlich zwölf Tage im Jahr. Aber es kann natürlich Verfahren geben, die deutlich länger dauern oder so, mit mehreren Tagen. Es gab auch mal Verhandlungen schon mit hundert Tagen. Und dann bist du halt hundert Tage pro Jahr beim Gericht, muss die bezahlt werden. weil man ist ja als Land von den Chefen abhängig, weil das Gericht funktioniert hier so, man braucht zwei Leute aus dem Volk, die den Richter im Zweifel überstimmen können. Super spannend und es gibt, das ist natürlich für True Crime Fans auch gerade richtig spannend, es gibt dann das truest, the truest of crimes, gibt es ja Fälle, wo man vorher zum Beispiel so WhatsApp-Verläufe und so Chat-Verläufe bekommt. Ach Gott, aber sind das denn, also jetzt nichts gegen die Personen, aber sind das denn nicht einfach Leute, die an den intimen Details von anderen Menschen interessiert sind, eigentlich Voyeur und schlechte Menschen? Die entscheiden über das Schicksal? Boah, aber nach der Logik werden ja Anwälte zum Beispiel auch sehr schlechte Menschen. Ja, weiter. Richter auch, also dann bricht halt alles zusammen, wenn du jetzt anfängst. Ja gut, das stimmt. Sind Polizisten nicht nur Leute, die Leute schlagen wollen. Ja, okay, weiter. Feuerwehrmenschen wollen die nicht eigentlich. Einfach nur Leute das spürzen. Nein, du machst mal. Also ich meine, da kann man jetzt aufhören. Und Rettungsanitäter nicht einfach nur Leute küssen. Leute küssen und über Rot fahren. Also deswegen verstehe ich deine Logik nicht so ganz. Ja, ja, ja. Man weiss es ja nicht, man muss ja immer aufpassen. Es braucht ja auch einen, der da ein Auge drauf hat, und das bin ich halt dann. Und dann hat jemanden, durfte man Fragen stellen. Dann hat jemanden auch Fragen gestellt, so ja, was ist denn eigentlich, wenn man vorbelastet ist und vielleicht so ein paar Sugar Points hat und Angst hat vor manchen Themen oder Dinge zu sehen, sehr grafische Dinge zu sehen, geht ja manchmal auch um Gewalttaten. Es ging hier im Konkreten um, nicht um ein Gericht, sondern verschiedene. Da war es noch Leute vom Arbeitsgericht, aber da war es noch Leute vom Jugendgericht und Zivilblablabla, alle wurden unterwiesen. Das heißt, es können auch da Mordfälle bei sein, bei manchen Menschen, die da saßen. Dann wurde die Frage gestellt und dann hieß es ja, kann man nichts machen, man kann, dann muss man einfach damit leben können. Das fand ich interessant. Und dann hat die Polizei auf diese sehr ernste, der Richter auf diese sehr ernste Frage gesagt, natürlich gibt es auch manchmal Fälle, wie zum Beispiel, die im schlimmsten Fall um Kipo sich drehen oder ähnliche Sachen. Also Kipo, Kinderpornografie.
Und da habe ich gesagt, nee, nee, nee, geht nicht, geht nicht, geht nicht, geht nicht.
Ich selber als grosser Fan von Abkürzungen.
Ich dachte, der Satz geht in eine andere Richtung.
Als grosser Fan von Abkürzungen denke ich ich mir bei Kipo, nimm dir die Zeit. Absolut. Je schlimmer ein Wort ist, das, was dahinter steht, muss im Verhältnis zur Länge stehen. Man kann dem durch die Länge des Satzes auch eine gewisse Gravitas geben. Ja, und ich finde, es gibt manche Wörter, die werden in der Regel nicht in Eile gesprochen. Genau. Also wenn du dieses Thema diskutierst, dann hast du in der Regel nicht, ach scheiße, mein Zug fährt gleich, ich muss jetzt wirklich haushalten mit der Zeit. Den Satz nur rausbekommen. So, ich muss jetzt schon lol, lel, irgendwie lass uns mal irgendwie in der WG, am WE in der WG, tschau, tschüss, raus. Wenn du dieses Thema diskutierst, hast du in der Regel Zeit. Genau. Du hast den Nachmittag freigenommen. Ja. Du sagst nicht, weder das Kalenderwoche. So, richtig Kippus, du sagst Kinderpornografie. Da hab ich auch gedacht, gibt's dann Kimi, Kindes Missbrauch, vor allem wie oft hat diese Person die Abkürzung schon gesagt und musste sie direkt danach erklären, bis man sagt, ich spare keine Zeit mehr. Vielleicht ist diese Abkürzung schlecht, wenn ich sie jedes Mal erklären muss. Ja, exakt. Jedes Mal. Ja, vielleicht spare ich am Ende gar nicht so viel Zeit. Ich finde das sind doof. Das ist typisch, das ist auch mehr so ein Bragging an der falschen Stelle, finde ich. Wir haben so viel damit zu tun, mit so schlimmen Sachen, deswegen müssen wir eine Abkürzung dafür haben. Okay, Gegenentwurf ist es eine Art, sich auch davor zu schützen. Dass solche Abkürzungen es eher
abstrahieren, als wenn man das
ausspricht, als Gegenentwurf.
Ich möchte nur eine Gegenposition
halten. Ich mag, dass du jetzt
Advocate spielst, ich möchte dazu nur sagen, sollte man
als Richter nicht gerade nicht
das klein machen oder von sich distanzieren,
sondern es als den Schrecken wahrnehmen, der es ist
und auch so bestrafen und ist Kipo
nicht sogar eine komische Distanz und sollte man nicht sogar Leuten, die am Ende Urteile fällen, nicht Kipo sagen, weil das schon direkt, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen Lacher, wahrscheinlich in so einem Saal vor so, der Ausdruck Kipo, meine ich. Ach so, vor allem, ich denke erst an Kinderpolizei. Ich habe erst gedacht, wie Kripo dachte ich, ah, Kinderpolizei, das sind die Kinder, die dann irgendwie so ein Kuscheltier verhaften oder so.
Das klingt süss, Kino und Kripo.
Und das geht dann vor Gericht. Kann ja auch sein, aber okay. Ja, ich finde das sehr. Aber kannst du nicht einfach in Urlaub fahren? Also ich will das jetzt gar nicht unter den Schöffel stellen, dass du sagst, 100 Tage Verhandlungen, aber kannst du nicht nach 20 Tagen einfach nach Rom fahren und dann einfach in Rom Gelato geniessen auf dem Piazzo? Gelato und Antipasto. Was spricht konkret dagegen, einfach zu gehen? Am Trevi-Brunn die Bruschetta sich rein zu pfeffern. Ja, genau. Und dann so schön ein Tattufo und Gelato. Bist du ein leckeres Tiramisu? Also ist das nicht eine Möglichkeit?
Nein. Weißt du, was passiert, wenn du nicht kommst zur Richtverhandlung?
Die Polizei steht vor deiner Tür. Im Zweifel stehen die, während du Gelato-Essen am Piazzo stehst,
da kommt die Polizei.
Die Karabinieri kommen an und sagen no no no no, Chefe.
Ja, okay, aber wenn du dich jetzt dem Chefendienst zu lange entziehst, dann kommst du vor das Gericht. Und wer, wenn alle mitmachen, fällt dann das Urteil. Genau, alle Cheffen, wir einen da langer Dominoeffekt, streiken, streiken, dann haben wir ein Riesenproblem. Nee, dann wird gedraftet. In manchen Kreisen, Landkreisen wird ja auch sogar, genau, es ist nicht stellst du nicht zur Wahl, sondern es werden Leute ausgewählt. Wir lachen immer USA aus mit ihrem dummen Jerry-Duty-System, das offensichtlich nicht funktioniert. Wir können das Wort nicht aussprechen, das ist auch ein großes Problem. Aber dabei sollte man immer bedenken, immer wenn du auf jemanden zeigst, zeigen vier, fünf bis acht Finger, zeigen drei Finger auf dich und ein Finger auch nach oben.
Ja, weil du ganz krumme Finger hast.
Weil du die Pistole hast.
Und einer zeigt dir den Himmel, vergiss das nicht. Das war auch so spannend. Da war nämlich neulich so ein Bericht über diesen Stormy Daniels Trump Fall, irgendwie so ein CNN-Bericht. Und dann wurde, weil es ist ja so, dass vorher beide Anwälte, der Kläger und der Verteidigerpartei, können entscheiden, ob Leute aus der Jury rausfliegen oder nicht.
Und selbst aus der Jury können Leute sagen, nee, ich bin befangen, ich möchte raus. Ja.
Und dann war eine Ukrainerin, eine junge Ukrainerin, die erst seit mehreren Monaten ist, ich wurde Staatsbürgerin in den USA, lebt da und seit kurzem und hat direkt den Brief ins Haus und sie wurde geholt.
Willkommen.
Genau, Jury Duty, hallo, willkommen in den USA.
Ja.
Und sie wusste gar nicht genau, was passiert, ist gerade erst da, alles noch neu, sie kommt da an und alle setzen sich hin und dann läuft Donald Trump zur Anklagebank. Und das ist natürlich das Weirdeste, was passieren kann. Und dann hat sie gesagt, nee, sie ist befangen, sie kann nicht mitmachen. Vor allem, also das ist ja jetzt eine allgemeine Frage, wer ist denn nicht befangen bei dem Thema, oder? So, und jetzt haben wir gefragt, wer bleibt sitzen? Also gibt es jemanden, der neutral zu Donald Trump steht? Also es gibt doch. Entweder du bist Wähler von ihm, Wählerin, oder du bist Gegner. Man müsste eigentlich irgendwie so eine ganz entfernte Gegend, wo Leute im Wald leben, irgendwie so seit 20 Jahren, die nichts mitbekommen haben. Und die, so Wolfskinder oder so, die müsste man holen, die könnten vielleicht ein gerechtes Urteil sprechen. Aber also das Gesetzbuch zerreissen als sehr mächtige Geste. Als sehr mächtige Metapher. Für was? Das ist auch nicht unsere Aufgabe. Das muss der Gerichtszeichner entscheiden, wie er das illustriert. Draußen, das Feuilleton. Wann hat das Feuilleton zur letzten Folge von uns besprochen? Ja, das ist auch schon weiter, ja. Aber das stimmt, das ist schwer, da Leute zu finden. Also, jetzt glaube ich, es bleiben die krassesten Leute sitzen. Die krassesten Gegner und die krassesten Befürworter. Das heißt, das ist 50-50, jede Seite hat die anderen aussortiert und will die eigenen Unterstützer dabei haben. Genau, die milden Befürworter würden sagen, ja, ich bin befangen, ich mag den Mager. Ja, das stimmt, ohne das halt auch der Trick, rauszukommen. Oder wenn du keinen Jewel-Duty hast, kommst du da mit so einem roten Hut und dann wirst du sofort rausgeschmissen. Und dann sagst du, ah Mensch, jetzt muss ich nach Roma. Du weißt ja nicht, wer da drin ist. Also das geht nicht, weil du weißt nicht, wer kommt. Ach so, okay. Na gut. Dann hat sich jemand strafbar gemacht bei der Unterweisung, fand ich auch spannend, weil er gesagt hat, meine Frau ist auch Schöffin und da habe ich manchmal mitbekommen, dass in manchen Fällen das und das passiert. Und das Erste, was sie gesagt haben, wirklich bei der Unterweisung war, man darf mit niemandem diese Fälle sprechen, es gilt einfach Schweigepflicht. Und da ist zwischen dem jemand diese Fragen gestellt und dann beide so, was? Und da habe ich so gedacht, oder war das so ein Termin, wo die gucken, wer ist hier überhaupt geeignet für den Cheffenjob?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und dann so da hinten raus, raus. Dass sie die letzten drei Trottel einfach nie aufrufen, weil sie die vermerken in der Akte als Depp, D. Ja, Depp, D, Depp, D, D, D, D, D, D, raus. Depp. Aber ich finde, also das ist ja fernab der Realität. Jeder weiss, dass wenn man sagt, bespricht das mit niemandem, dass damit gemeint ist, jeder hat ein paar Menschen, mit denen man mehr oder weniger alles bespricht.
So, also ich glaube nicht, dass das richtig ist.
Aber bei Therapeuten, Therapeutinnen, klar.
Natürlich der Therapeute, als ob der nach Hause geht und sagt, Alter, was für ein Vollidiot, ey.
Ich sagte ihm seit Jahren, er soll irgendwie ausziehen, die Beziehung funktioniert nicht und der Depp kommt jede Woche wieder. Ich meine, sind Therapeuten nicht auch einfach nur Leute, die lästern wollen? Also ich meine, ich will es ja nur mal sagen. Als Therapeut würde ich so viel dafür geben, die Leute, über die gesprochen wird, mal kennenzulernen. Ach so. Weil man sieht ja nur... Weil ich denke ja, ich jetzt als Therapeut würde denken, so nach der zwanzigsten Sitzung würde ich sagen, ja gut, aber jetzt kenne ich nur deine Geschichte. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann will ich doch irgendwie diese Person sehen, über die er die ganze Zeit lästert. Ist diese schreckliche Frau. Ja, ja, dieser Florentin klingt ja unglaublich interessant, über den du da immer erzählst.
Der klingt super anstrengend, nervig, narzisstisch und antisozial. Aber das ist ja zum Beispiel, es gibt diese Serie, die tatsächlich sehr gut ist, In Treatment heisst die. Die israelische Serie, nicht? Ist, glaube ich, ein israelisches Original, was dann von den USA geremakt wurde. Und er geht zum Therapeuten, der in jeder Folge halt einen anderen Patienten hat und mit ihm redet. Und ich dachte, ich habe die erste Folge gesehen und habe gesagt, okay, easy, leicht, der Twist ist, dass die Fälle der Patienten miteinander verbunden sind. Dass der eine immer redet über, ah, der andere ist so narzisstisch und dann hast du nächste Woche den Narzissten und dann kommt irgendwann raus, dass die Zusammenhängen war nicht so, riesen Enttäuschung, konnte die Serie nicht geniessen. Ein von fünf Sternen. Für mich müssen Serien so sein, dass meine persönlichen Vermutungen stimmen, dann macht es die Serie falsch. Ich will, dass die Leute sich so verhalten, wie ich mich verhalten würde, und wenn diese dies nicht machen, dann ist die Serie schlecht und falsch. Und deswegen kannst du nur gucken. Dexter, Manc, Breaking Bad. Die Simpsons. Und die Szenen mit Bart Simpson. Ja, ich fand das alles sehr spannend. Man darf nicht das Gesicht verziehen, man darf nicht offensichtlich ... Das würde mir am schwierigsten fallen, weil ich bin ein offenes Buch. Wenn jemand was Dummes vor mir sagt, kann ich das nicht verbergen. Ja, ich hab ein Resting-Guilty-Face. Immer wenn ich mich entspanne, dann hab ich so ein, oh, du gehst so was von den Knasten. So was so? So wie, äh, vergiss es, Alter. Ja, und dann kann nämlich da die, ähm, die Verteidigerposition, der Anwalt, die Anwältin, kann dann sagen, ah, da ist jemand befangen, ich kriege die ganze Zeit so guilty vibes, das gefällt mir nicht und dann kann der Chefin ausgetauscht werden und dadurch kann eine Verzögerung des ganzen Prozessverlaufs gecheckert werden, ausgelöst werden und das wird oft genutzt, um die Gegensätze zu verwirren. Sorry, das geht mir heute alles zu sehr an der realität vorbei ich weiss ihr in eurem juristen helfen bei den turm nur sagen aber realistisch ist das bullshit meine mutter zum beispiel war auch chefin geil am krigsdienstverweigerungsgericht es gab ja wehrdienst und dann hast du den verweigert kriegsdienst verweigert dien Dienst an der Waffe verweigert, musstest du schon schreiben, Gewissensschreiben schreiben. Und bei manchen haben die Verantwortlichen einfach gesagt, ne, wir lassen dich nicht verweigern. Und dann mussten die vor Gericht und vor Gericht nochmal ihren Fall darlegen. Meine Mutter war Chefin mit dem erklärten Ziel, jeden rauszuhauen. Und das erklärte Ziel im Privaten war dein T-Shirt an, ich hau dich auch, sie hat mit Sicherheit nicht den Leuten da bei Unterweisung gesagt, mein erklärtes Ziel wäre übrigens alle Rieksisverweigerer durchzulassen. Das weiss ich nicht, aber das war auf jeden Fall so, das fällt ja irgendwann auf, oder, dass jedes Mal immer, weil ich als Chefe, ich würde ja versuchen neutral zu sein, würde ich sagen, okay, ich habe jetzt zwei Leute unschuldig gesprochen, die müssen den nächsten schuldig sprechen. Also ich muss ja, nee, aber ich darf ja nicht, ich muss ja selber meine eigenen Vorurteile überprüfen, faktisch. Aber statistisch und Neutralität hat ja nichts miteinander zu tun. Ah, meinst du nicht? Statistik ist nicht neutral.
Naja, aber es gibt ja schon eine gewisse Quote, oder? In wie viel Prozent der Fällen ist der Angeklagte schuldig? Das kann man doch juristisch, das wird doch irgendeine Zahl geben.
Da gibt es auch oben im Verfassungsgericht so eine grosse digitale Anzeige, wo wie so ein Aktienkurs der aktuelle Schuldkurs so. Und wenn du keine Zeit hast, dich dir vorzubereiten, guckst halt, ah, 30% sind schuldig, einer war ja hier unschuldig, next, so, und da hast du dann Wert. Bestimmt, oder? Genau so ist es wahrscheinlich. Schreib mir mal eine Zahl bitte in den Kommentaren. Aber kannst du sagen, wie lange war deine Mutter dann Chefin? 16-Jährige, weiß ich. Das kommt bei mir deinen Döner hoch. So viel Döner hast du gegessen. Jesus. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht. Ich habe das sogar nie mitbekommen aktiv. Vermutlich stimmt das auch alles nicht. Höchstwahrscheinlich, weil es meine Dublin, meine Tante, die mal irgendwie im Fernsehenrichter Alexander Holt gesehen hat. Ach nee, das war eigentlich mein Opa und das war kein Chef im Gericht, sondern die Feuerwehr und dann macht es alles keinen Sinn. Aber das ist das Gute, deswegen kann ich ja im Podcast alles erzählen, weil es wahrscheinlich komplett gelogen ist. Ja! Aber als Kind, du kriegst ja nicht mit, was deine Eltern machen. Nein. Deine Eltern sagen ja auch nicht, so mein Kind, ich gehe jetzt zum Schöpfengericht, sondern die Kinder sagen, ich bin weg, bis achst du nur ciao und du okay, geil, ich schau Detektiv Conan. Schreibe mich nicht an, willst du es sagen, ich stehe direkt neben dir, ich stehe an der Tür, sag nicht immer, ich bin weg, tschau! Detektiv Conan war so geil.
Ah, und dann denkst du dir, geil, ich schau Detektiv Conan.
Und wo meine Eltern sind, ist zweitrangig.
Das ist so, wenn die ausser Sicht sind, sind die weg, sind die in ihrer Erwachsenenwelt,
sitzen an einem Schreibtisch und stempeln irgendwelche Blätter.
Und ja, Mr. Jakamoto, die zahlen für diesen Monat.
Man weiß nichts über die Eltern.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es bin nicht nur ich. Ich glaube, man weiss manchmal, man kennt Geschichten aus der Jugend, man weiss grob, was haben sie für Musik gehört, darüber nähert man sich wahrscheinlich mal an der Jugend oder sowas. Ich weiss, meine Mom war Beatles-Fan, meine auch. war in der Wow. Haben wir die gleiche Mutter? Krass, ey. Man sollte nicht mehr kennenlernen, die würden sie aber war also krass so flowerpower zeit mitgemacht also war eigentlich vor beatles war dann ja so typisch diese ganze draggy erste marioanawelle so wahrscheinlich diese zeit mitgemacht und dann weiß ich nichts mehr und dann wurde es meine mutter ja und da sind so mega viele jahre sind so an accounted for ja also das ist nicht so ich weiß dann schon eine kindheit so wie die frühe kindheit doch die dabei ja aber da bin ich dann so dabei, aber ich meine, die Zeit so zwischen 25 und 35, das sind zehn Jahre, was hast du ja gemacht? Und das ist ja gerade auch das Jahr, in dem ich gerade stecke. Das fände ich schon interessant. Man redet über die Zeit nicht so richtig. Ich meine, unsere Kinder haben natürlich den Vorteil, dass sie sich 680 Podcast-UFO-Folgen anhören können und nach zwei denken wahrscheinlich, ah, war ich irgendwann anders mal und so und dann was der erzählt, ist eh alles gelogen und so. Ich muss mich allerdings korrigieren, meine Mutter ist kein Beatles-Fan, sondern eher Rolling Stones-Fan. Dann würden die sich hassen. Dann würden die sich hassen. Oder The Rolling Stones, ich weiss nicht. The Rolling Stones. Aber eigentlich The Rolling Stones Stones of Yorkshire. Eigentlich. Dann irgendwann The Rolling Stones, dann nur noch Rolling Stones. Rolling. Und dann sogar nur noch Stones. The Stones. The Beatles? The Beatles. The Beatles. Ja, ja, okay. The Clouseo. Clueso? Ne, Clueso steht für sich. Also Clueso, Cluesum, Clueso, Cluesibus, Cluesar, Cluesorum, Cluesus, Cluesus, Cluesus, O-Konjugation, Deklination. Wir wissen es nicht. Nicht, wir wissen das es alle. Ich glaube, ich habe nicht den besten möglichen Döner bekommen, ehrlich gesagt. Was hat gefehlt? Wo ist das? Erst mal wo ist das? Wir sind in Köln. Ja, hier auf der Tour. Wir sind nämlich in Köln. Hier auf der Bahn, auf der langen Kreisbahn. Die kann den berühmten LP-10-Lukas-Bedolski-Döner kaufen. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich wollte eigentlich zu dem neuen, da war so ein Dönerladen, der hat neu aufgemacht und der hatte so einen Wink, so eine aufblasbare Winkpuppe. Ja. Das haben wir noch nie gesehen, ausserhalb von USA, so das, und der hat so gewunken hat die ganze Zeit und da dachte ich mir, das überzeugt mich, aber da ich nie Döner esse, habe ich das nicht mehr noch. Ja genau, das hat was am Elbo und winkt die ganze Zeit. Und es macht auch dieses Geräusch und es macht es noch viel lauter und dann steht immer so ein Junge, der mit dem Messer in der Hand steht und dann, manchmal fahre ich nämlich vorbei zu so Zeiten, wo niemand Döner ist, und dann steht dieser Junge mit dem Messer und dieser Maschine davor, direkt so einen Meter von dem entfernt, auf Ohrenhöhe. Und er macht mit seinem Wut und werdet es? Ja, es ist saunärkend. Und alles in dem Laden, und niemand weiss es, aber alles in dem Laden ist perfekt auf diesen Rhythmus synchronisiert, und es fällt niemandem auf, weil man komplett eingenordert ist von diesem Takt. Irgendwer in der Geschichte der Menschheit ist irgendwer mal in so einen Laden gegangen, weil da eine Maschine vorsteht, die in diesen Laden deutet, durch Aufblasen und Abblasen zu bedeuten. Ich finde es mega. Warum? Weil du es, weil es den... Weil mich die Technik fasziniert. Du kennst den Kontext. Dich fand es fasziniert, glaube ich, der US-Kontext. Auch möglich, auch möglich. Ich kenne das aus Filmen und Ser Serien, die ich mag. Ich meine aber ursprünglich der Gedanke, es bringt etwas, das ist so ein Ding, so ein Wackelarm. Ich mag so billige Touristenfallen-Sachen, ich mag diese Ästhetik irgendwie so, ich mag auch diese billigen Plastik-Einweg-Einmal-Bullshit, ich mag irgendwie diesen schlechten Geschmack irgendwie, habe ich da was dafür? Und dann wollte ich da eigentlich hingehen, hatte aber zu, musste dann nochmal zurückgehen zum anderen und dann war wirklich so der Dönerspieß, oben krustig, knusprig, perfektes Fleisch, unten nackt, roh. Quasi entblösst. Wie so ein Hirn. Es hatte schon fast was peinliches. Ein rohes Hirn. Ja, und dann dachte ich mir, okay. Guck dich mich an, ich bin ganz roh. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich will noch nicht abschneiden, ich bin noch roh. Ich bin noch nicht fertig. Ich bin noch nicht fertig. Ich bin noch so jung. Und dann... Das Kitzelt, das Messer kitzelt. Aber ich bin noch nicht fertig, nein, nein, da musst du noch warten. Ja, und im Stock drüber, ich bin bereit, ich bin bereit, die können jetzt los, die hoppe schienzreiche Kruste.
Ich noch nicht.
Und dann dachte ich natürlich, dass da von oben abgeschnitten werden wird, aber nein, es wurde komplett nochmal unten ins jungfräuliche, pinke Fleisch geschnitten.
Und ich dachte mir, warum kriege ich nicht das gute Knusprige?
Und dann dachte ich, vielleicht ist das so für Stammkunden oder so, dass es eine Zweiklassengesellschaft gibt und man wirklich sagt, okay, für die wird das aufgehoben, da haben die nochmal eine gute Schicht.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. so für Stammkunden oder so, dass es wirklich eine Zweiklassengesellschaft gibt und man wirklich sagt, okay, für die wird das aufgehoben, da haben die ja noch mal eine gute Schicht. Wie damals, als wir mal gedreht haben und dann haben die, er hat uns einen Dönerladen, da weiß ich auch nicht, wie diese ganze Geschichte zustande gekommen ist. Ihr habt den Döner gedreht? Nein, wir mussten mal damals was drehen. Ihr seid verantwortlich, dass der Döner sich dreht. Und dann brauchten wir dafür einen Dönerspieß. Und dann sind die in den Laden gegangen, so zwei Setrunner, und kamen mit einem Dönerspieß wieder. Dann haben wir mit dem gedreht. Im Rohn? Ja, und dann haben wir den wieder zurückgebracht und dann haben die den einfach wieder reingeklemmt. Und seitdem sind dann alle aus dem Team nicht mehr zu dem Döner gegangen. Was? Und das war mein Lieblingsdöner, Mosaik. Ja, aber was glaubst du denn, was die davor mit dem Döner machen, als ob die den irgendwie chirurgisch, natürlich liegt der im Auto, auf der Rückbank, natürlich liegt der auf der Rückbank im Auto und fällt einmal beim Bremsen von der Rückbank auf dem Boden, da wo noch direkt Bulldosen rumliegen. Ja, ja komm, egal. Dann nimmt man so einen Handfeger, der vorher an ganz schlimmen Orten war und fällt dann so so diese Zigarettenreste, macht man dann so weg von dem Ding. Der schon alles gesehen hat, dieser Feger, wo die Borsten dann noch so zwei Zentimeter lang sind, der einfach schon alles mitgebracht hat. Was haben denn Leute gegen Dreck eigentlich? Da habe ich gedacht, was wird denn gemacht mit fucking Dönerspießen, was man nicht weiß. Ja, aber was sollen die denn machen? Was ist denn so ein Dönerspießwert? 500 Euro, die schmeissen dann nicht den weg, weil der einmal... 500 Euro? Ja, oder was kostet ein Dönerspieß? Wie viel Döner stecken in einem so einem Dönerspieß? Wobei, da kenne ich auch volle und volle, ne? Also ich kenne schmale und ich kenne die dicken Ringer. Die richtigen Wämser, jajaja. Wahnsinn, und die gehen dann alle weg an den einen Tag? Aber was kostet ein Dönerspieß? Ich glaube, 500 Euro ist gar... Du lachst mich immer lauthals aus und merkst dann, vielleicht ist es gar nicht so falsch. Was kostet ein Dönerspieß? Ich glaube, fünf, vier Euro ist gar ... Du lachst mich immer lauthals aus und merkst dann, vielleicht ist es gar nicht so falsch. Was kostet ein Dönerspieß? Ich glaube, viel billiger Dönerspieß. Ich glaube, viel billiger, 200 Euro sage ich. Ah, zwischen 39 und 260 Euro. 39? Okay. Gut, danke, Internet, für diese Fluxer-Recherche, danke schönön. Krass. Aber das kann ich jetzt nicht verstehen, also muss ich kurz noch einmal gucken. Aber das ist auch die Frage, ne, Hähnchenlamm, auch die Frage. Ich finde, also ich habe auch für mich einmal einen Gamechanger-Döner gegessen. 300 Euro, ja. Wo es hieß ja, ich will einen Döner und dann hat der nette Herr direkt so eine Schüssel gegriffen. Und dann dachte ich, in welchem Film bin ich denn jetzt geraten? Der Döner Teller. Wo bin ich denn jetzt? So, und dann wurde das Fleisch in die Schüssel geworfen. Dann wurde Salat in die Schüssel geworfen, Zwiebeln in die Schüssel. Alle Bestandteile wurden in diese Schüssel geworfen. Kann ich raten, was passiert? Bitte. Er hat das durchmengt, durchmischt und dann ins Fladenbrot gemacht. Wie amazing ist das denn? Und ich dachte mir, sag mal, jetzt sind wir doch mal am Ende. Das ist ja perfekt. Der Döner-Evolution angekommen, das war perfekt. Und seitdem denke ich mir, warum macht das nicht jeder so? Ich meine, ich will nicht wissen, wie oft diese Schüssel gewaschen wird am Tag, wahrscheinlich nie. Weil du hast nur immer eine Sache im Mund. Ja, aber das Ding ist halt so, willst du den perfekten Döner überhaupt haben? Oder geniesst du gerade, dass du nach dem Perfekten besuchen musst? Frag die Frage, stell die Frage. Ich stell die Frage, ich stell sie jetzt. Nee, ich meine, stell als Dönermann, Dönerfrau die Frage. Sagt, wird denn gemischt oder so? Du kannst nicht selber entscheiden. Wenn du Leuten immer das gibst, was sie wollen, dann merken sie, dass sie das, was sie wollen, eigentlich gar nicht wirklich wollen.
Deswegen ist Subway so wahnsinnig erfolgreich.
Ja, ist es wirklich wahnsinnig erfolgreich? Das ist die erfolgreichste Food-Fast-Food-Kette. Food-Fat-Kette. Ja, aber das ist, wo ich mir dachte, warum nicht immer so. Es gibt ja auch diesen Trend von diesen zackten Sandwiches, dass du so die Zutaten, also
dann Schinken, Käse, Salat, dass du das
alles auf dein Schneiderbrett tust, alles zerhackst,
durchmischt und dann zwischens Brot
tust, wo wir, finde ich, schon
gefährlich nahe an einem Döner sind,
weil das ist für mich ein Döner, ein Döner hat keine Schichten,
sondern Stücke,
die mosaikhaft
aneinandergereiht gehören.
Mit dem Dreck von der Rückbank. Die zusammengehören, ja genau, mit dem Dreck vom Dreh, wo das einmal in Molton eingedrückt wurde.
Dreh-Dreck-Müll.
Genau. Und deswegen finde ich, darf man das nicht vermischen, aber das war für mich ein Game-Changer, die Schüssel, und seitdem vermisse ich diese Schüssel tatsächlich jedes Mal.
Aber klar, es gibt natürlich Döner-Puristen, weil es ist ja, glaube ich, eine mathematische Unmöglichkeit, das zu schichten, so dass du in einem Winkel, also das ist ja, also da müsste man ja wirklich mal einen Nobelpreisträger drauf ansetzen. Du hast ein Winkelgefäss, das du mit Schichten füllst, was ja, also die Schicht selbst muss ja auch einen Winkel haben. Die Schicht müsste ja keilförmig sein, damit du wirklich wie in so einem Rad, so einem Orangenstück hast. Die Definition eines Winkels ist die Verjüngung. Richtig. Und das ist ja letztlich schon quasi intrinsisch in der Idee des Winkels ist ja schon mit drin, dass weniger Schichten Platz haben unten. Genau. Am Ende hast du ein Stück Fleisch ohne alles und Soße, da war noch nie Satsiki oder Schaf, was auch immer das eigentlich für eine Soße ist, da war nie Schaf dran. Ich finde, man müsste das noch, also ich möchte jetzt einfach mal auch plädieren, werft Kulturen mal bitte über Bord. Weil was heißt Kultur? Kultur heißt, das haben wir immer schon so gemacht, Tradition, aber Kultur bremst Innovation. Ja, das stimmt, klar. Ich würde sagen, nimmt alles nochmal komplett kontextfrei ins Labor. Zum Beispiel, es gibt ja, also wenn du sagst, Döner jetzt in, alle Dönerzutaten in den Mixer zu werfen und durchzumixen und dann das Püree in ein Dönerbrot zu füllen, ist eklav, die Vorstellung. weil es zu fein ist, zu grob hingegen funktioniert auch nicht, weil du hast nicht alle Komponenten, also muss es ja in den Sweetspot die perfekte Komponentengrösse für einen Döner. So, und jetzt These, Gegenthese. Ich habe noch keine These aufgestellt, aber bitte? Doch, du hast gesagt, werft mal die Leute über Bord, werft mal Menschen anderer Kultur über Bord. Ja, das war eher ein Auf war eher ein Dogma, aber gut. Du hast gesagt, werft man Menschen anderer Kultur über Bord.
Ja, ja, das war eher ein Aufruf als eine These, aber gut. Du hast gesagt, lass mal die Tradition um den Haufen werfen und gucken, wie es richtig geil ist, wie ich die verstanden habe. Genau. Ich glaube, es ist so, weil es so richtig geil ist, weil das hat in seiner Zeit bestanden, in Tests der Zeit bestanden. Ähm, denn zum Beispiel kann man ja, haben ja Leute herausgefunden, wie können Menschen am besten verdauen. Dinge, ja, zum Beispiel, du hast ein riesen Menü vor dir, aus Vorspeisen, Hauptspeisen, Nachspeisen, süss, bla bla bla. Da hat man herausgefunden, dass wie wir das essen schon am sinnvollsten ist. Wenn der Magen vorbereitet wird mit herzhaften Köstlichkeiten und dann das Dessert kommt, hat der Körper am meisten davon und wir nehmen sogar am wenigsten zu. Warum, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber der Magen ist vorbereitet, was auch immer. Aber es ist eine sehr, sehr sinnvolle Reihenfolge. Und für uns ist das arbiträr, es hat sich einfach so ergeben, es ist Tradition, es ist Kultur.
Ich würde sagen nein, wahrscheinlich hat sich das so ergeben, weil es sinnvoll ist. Und ich glaube, wenn du das Lineal der Perfektion der Nobelpreisträger anlegen würdest, an vielen Dingen, die wirklich seltsam, weird, irgendwie entstanden wie Döner ansetzt, käme heraus, ist schon sehr perfekt. Aber jetzt also, wie ist das jetzt evolutionär erklärbar? Haben schon unsere Urväter erst das gebratene Reh gegessen und dann die Beeren? Weil das schon, und dann hat sich der sich der Magen so entwickelt oder ist es? Ja, das ist ein Henne-Ei-Problem, was du auch machst. Ja, weil ich meine, hätten die Menschen das immer andersrum gegessen würden, hätte es sich wahrscheinlich anders entwickelt. Und das ist ja die Frage, was kam zuerst? Also ist erst die Konvention und dann die Natur oder andersrum? Oder was soll das? Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass Leute sich, es hat sich rumgesprochen, was bekömmlicher ist und dann macht man das eher. Und jetzt kommt aber die nächste Frage. Schmeckt das Essen auch besser, wenn es so zubereitet ist, dass es funktioniert? Zum Beispiel Kohl und Kümmel. Kohl und Kümmel wird gern zusammengegessen und Kümmel hilft dabei, Kohl zu verdauen. Und dann dachte ich mir auch auch hier also hat es irgendjemand mal gecheckt und gesagt okay aber jetzt breite ich das so zu und es wurde einfach teil der tradition oder es bekömmel ich ja oder nee oder anders unser körper gibt uns signale und sagt nie unser geschmack weil der körper sagt ja auch die dinge die du brauchst Mein Geschmack sagt mir Zucker, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos, buenos. In der Welt lebst, die nicht für deinen Körper gedacht ist, sondern weil dein Körper ja denkt, oh, was gut schmeckt, ist viel Energie.
Also ist dein Körper schlau und vielleicht
checkt der Körper auch, ah, Kohle und Kümmel,
schmeckt gut zusammen,
weil ich es dann besser verdauen kann. Never ist
das die Reihenfolge. Und das ist nämlich
genau, das ist so ein bisschen so, damals hat er diese,
ich war ja in Kolumbien und Peru.
Okay, dann hast du ja automatisch recht.
Deswegen, nee, da kam ja dann,
haben die ja irgendwann diese Koka-Blätter
von den ganzen Milliarden
Pflanzen im Wald gefunden,
um gegen die Höhe klarzukommen.
Weil dieses eine Blatt, auf dem sie rumkauen,
aus dem später
der Wirkstoff Kokain ja auch synthetisiert
wurde, diese sind genau
der Wirkstoff, der da drin ist, lässt sich
mehr Sauerstoff im Blut aufnehmen
und du kommst in der Höhe besser klar, wo die Luft
weniger Sauerstoff. Ja, aber jetzt mal die Frage, warum wächst diese Pflanze dort, wo es hohe Berge gibt? Also ist nicht sogar die Natur in der ersten Schrift. Halt dein Maul! Lässt die Natur nicht dort diese Pflanzen wachsen, die nicht auch automatisch auf den Berg gehen? Das ist der grösste Unsinn, der nicht jemals gehört hat. Die Natur bereitet dir den Weg. Gott, eine göttliche Instanz hat dem Menschen da Pflanzen. Ja, oder der Mensch hat sich so entwickelt, dass er diese Dinge nutzt, um die Probleme zu lösen, die in der Nähe liegen. Nee, und wenn ich es anwende auf dein Kümmmmel, Kümmel, Henne, Ei Problem, dann wie ein Putzwagen, wie ein Putzwagen, ein Zug, die S19, dann wäre es ja so, die Pflanze, die wir nehmen, gibt uns genau das, was wir brauchen. Körper sagt, diese Pflanze, Körper sagt, wir brauchen diese kleine Pflanze. Aber der Körper hat ja auch noch eine Rolle, mitzuspielen. Der Körper hat ein Problem und der Körper hat Werkzeuge. Nein, der Körper hat keine Werkzeuge, der Körper hat einen Ekelnied, der Körper weiss nicht, was er will. Okay, pass mal auf. Du lebst an einem Fluss. Allergie hat ja auch keinen Sinn. Du lebst an einem Fluss. Und du, wie soll ich über den Fluss rüberkommen? Also nimmst du die Bäume und verarbeitest sie zu einem Fluss und fährst über den Fluss. Vielleicht ist es doch kein Baum. Der Mensch, der Körper hat auch das Problem, ich habe gewisse Probleme und ich habe gewisse Dinge, die in meinen Körper reingestopft werden. Also entwickle ich Prozesse, um diese Dinge, die in meinen Körper reingestopft zu werden, so zu verarbeiten, um meine Probleme zu lösen. Kann doch auch sein, dass der Körper nur deswegen diese Pflanze so umsetzen kann, dass sie gegen die Höhe hilft, weil er ständig Probleme mit Höhe hat und halt gerade, metaphorisch, dieses Stück Holz nimmt, um Fluss rauszubauen. Ist es nicht, der Körper macht... Der Körper macht... Ockhams Rasiermesser. Die einfachste Erklärung ist die richtige und ich glaube, es ist doch viel, viel einfacher, dass sie einfach alle Pflanzen probiert haben und die halt häufiger genommen haben, die einen positiven Einfluss auf deren direktes Leben hatte. Ja. So, jetzt meine Frage, weil ich habe nämlich diese Woche auch noch was anderes gegessen. Kümmeldöner. Und zwar eine Pizza Hawaii. Und jetzt, aber ich war sehr geschockt. Du hast schon gehört, mal, dass im Milieu der sauren Ananas mit dem Lactose, das Kochsalz des Schinkens, im feuchten Milieu der Ananas mit dem Käse gemeinsam Krebs, Superkrebs auslöst. Das weißt du. Absolut, aber jetzt ist meine Frage an dich, weil anscheinend war ich naiv, denn ich habe die Pizza aufgemacht, Pizza Hawaii und ich war geschockt, weil was würdest du erwarten, wenn du eine Pizza Hawaii bestellst? Was, jetzt habe ich eine, ich möchte, dass du die Frage präzise beantwortest und es kommt jetzt wirklich auch auf die Semantik an. Ja. Was ist auf einer Pizza Hawaii? Auf einer Pizza Hawaii finden wir. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie Pizza Hawaii gegessen. Was ich erwarten würde, wäre Schinken, Ananasstückchen und Käse. Also was, okay, aber interessant, dass du Käse sagst. Weil ich würde sagen, die Deutschen knallen Gouda auf die Salami, die Italiener nur Mozzarella, glaube ich. Deutsche, Gouda ist ein deutsches Phänomen. Weil ich würde nämlich sagen, auf einer Pizza Hawaii ist Schinken und Ananas. Weil auf einer Pizza ja ohnehin schon Käse ist. Du sagst ja nicht auf einer Schinkenpizza. Der Oberbegriff Hawaii begreift ja das Dreigestirn, das grosse Dreigestirn, dieses Triptychon aus Schinken, Käse, Ananas. Aber, und jetzt so dachte ich, eine Pizza hat ja schon Käse, also muss auf eine Pizza Hawaii Schinken und Ananas. Weil die ja schon in ihrer Rohform Käse beisteuert. Jetzt komme ich natürlich auch mit meiner Napoli-Nähe, wo ich dann immer denke, Käse ist nicht so wie auch Pizza. Es gibt auch, jetzt gibt es oder die Assi-Nähe, es gibt auch Nutella-Pizzen. Und andersherum gibt es auch Pizza ohne Käse. Das heißt, in jedem Fall hätte ich gerade den Käse aufgezählt als eine Zutat. Nee, wenn du sagst, ich hätte gerne eine Pizza mit Schinken, dann ist auf der Pizza, also natürlich Käse, wie immer, Schinken. Eine Pizza ist eine Pizza Margherita plus der Belag. Und jetzt zum Beispiel die Frage, wie viele verschiedene Käsesorten sind auf einer Pizza Quattro Formaggi? Ja, vier. Warum denn vier, wenn du sagst, ich finde nämlich eigentlich fünf. Nein, du hast keinen Gouda drauf. Aber die Gouda ist ja schon eine Käse. Und dann ja noch, also die Pizza ist benannt nach dem, was drauf ist. Und genau deswegen sage ich dir, habe ich gerade Käse aufgezählt, habe ich den Gouda gerade aufgezählt bei, was ist auf einer Hawaii-Pizza? Weil der Oberbegriff Pizza ist für mich nicht Käse, das die frage vielleicht wie definiert diese pizza ist glaube ich die pizza ist teig tomate käse nein eben nicht doch bohr ist das falsch es ist so falsch wenn du eine pizza salami bestellst dann erwartest du doch nicht teig tomate salami sondern da ist natürlich käse drauf kleiner tangente warum sind wir heute so weit weg von heute. Es ist doch offensichtlich. Kleine argumentative Tangente, türkische Pizza hat keinen Käse. Ja, aber das ist ja was anderes. Warum benimmt man dann, da würde man ja nicht im Deutschen den Begriff Pizza übernehmen. Wenn ich im türkischen Restaurant sitze, dann erwarte ich ja auch nicht eine italienische Pizza, das ist ja klar. Ich sag nur, du benutzt den Griff Pizza. Aber ich ruf ja an bei Piccolo Italiano und sag, ich hätt gern eine Pizza mit Schinken. Dann ist selbstverständlich, dass da Käse drauf ist. Aber selbst Tomate ist ja nicht normal. Es gibt ja diese neapolitanische Fiori Latte-Pizza. Stefan, dass du die Welt bereist hast und schon alle Ecken gesehen hast, das freut mich für dich. Aber wenn du bei einer Pizzeria anrufst und sagst, ich hätte gerne eine Pizza mit Salami, dann kriegst du eine Pizza mit Tomaten, Käse und Salami. Was ist das sonst? So, na klar genau und deswegen sag ich wenn du eine pizza hawai bestellst ist dann nicht noch mal extra käse drauf weil ja eid käse schon dabei ist und warum ist quattro formaggi sind es dann insgesamt vier käsesorten das ist ja immer anders das muss doch dann auch oben drauf sein eigentlich ist es pizza aber du willst ja trennt da formaggi aber du bist ja nicht so formstar du du willst ja immer die beste Pizza machen. Und wie Formstar wäre das jetzt, wenn du sagst, ah, jede Pizza, die ich mache, mache ich erst Teich, dann streiche ich drauf einen Kreis aus Tomatensauce, dann kommt jetzt die Beilage drauf, das wären in dem Fall vier verschiedene Käsesorten und jetzt mache ich obendrauf, weil ich es bei allen Pizzern mache, nochmal Gouda, weil dann so läuft das schön. Was ist das für ein Gericht? Das ist ja kein Gericht. Du willst doch die vier Viertel der Pizza mit verschiedenen Käsesorten haben. Manchmal mischen die das auch schon klar, aber eigentlich willst du wie bei Quattro Stagioni, willst du die vier verschiedenen Viertel haben. Und das würdest du ja als Pizzabäcker komplett zerstören, wenn du obendrauf dann einfach nur so wild ... Ja, unten drunter, aber ja, ich verstehe es total.
So, und bei deiner Hawaii ist nämlich für die optimale, ich finde es ja eh einen furchtbaren Affront, aber ich finde es ja dann wahnsinnig sinnvoll, gleichmäßig Pizza oben drüber zu kippen, äh Käse oben drüber zu kippen, damit du halt die optimale Essexperience ... Weil da ist es tatsächlich der Fall, dass ich das unterschiedlich erlebt habe. Manchmal, wenn du eine Pizza Hawaii bestellst, kriegst du eine Pizza Margherita mit Schinken und Ananas.
Manchmal kriegst du eine Pizza Margherita mit Schinken und Ananas.
Manchmal kriegst du eine Pizza Margherita mit Schinken, Ananas und noch Käse drauf.
Und das hat mich irritiert.
Weil das muss, finde ich, nicht sein. Das funktioniert für mich auch nicht.
Und ich habe den dann nochmal bestellt und habe gesagt, ohne, stand extra dabei, nochmal Käse oben drauf.
Habe gesagt, ohne Käse oben drauf, nur mit Margarita. Ich habe einen viel zu langen Absatz geschrieben. Also wollen Sie keine Hawaii. Okay, jetzt hör mal zu. Okay, jetzt hör mir mal zu. Jetzt hör mir zu. Ich will nur den Margarita-Käse. Plus Ananas, plus Schinken. Okay, also bestelle ich hier eine, weil Sie gerade Hawaii gesagt haben. Ja, aber Hawaii ist ja, aber Käse ist ja schon dabei, das muss ich ja nicht sagen. Aber Hawaii ist das, wie wir es hier verstehen und wie ich hier auch gerade auf mein Schaubild gucke, wo wir veranschaulicht haben, wo die verschiedenen Welten der Pizzeria sind, Hawaii ist für uns der Oberbegriff des Dreigestihens, aus Käse, Schinken und Ananas. Deswegen war ich gerade verwirrt, aber da meinen Sie eigentlich, was Sie bestellen wollen, und da finden wir uns ja jetzt, was Sie bestellen wollen, ist eine Margarita mit Schinken und Ananas. Wissen Sie, was ich esse, Döner? Also mit Kalb und mit Hähnchen. So, und ich widerspreche mir ja selber, merke ich schon, weil ich einerseits sage, Pizza Schinken ist Schinken auf Margarita, aber ich sage bei Hawaii, ich will nicht nochmal den externen Käse. Und mich hat das wirklich erschüttert, weil ich mir relativ sicher bin, dass wenn du dir zum Beispiel eine tiefkührende Restaurante Pizza Hawaii kaufst, ist keine Extrakäse drauf. Es ist nicht klar definiert, was eine Pizza ist, ob dieser Käse Teil des Belags ist oder Teil der Pizza. Du bist in deinem Kopf zu sehr drin. Wo gerade diese Käseinnen diese käse ist bei dir immer schon in der pizza mitgedacht da musst du dich mal von von freimachen aber dann würde es keinen sinn ergeben eine pizza prosciutto zu bestellen und selbstverständlich eine margarita mit prosciutto zu bekommen das ist einfach entstanden durch natürlich will niemand das bestellen niemand wenn es geil wäre wenn eine pizza geil wäre Schinken, dann hätte sich das durchgesetzt, dann hätte man eine Pizza Broschutto, wäre dann einfach eine Pizza mit Tomaten und Schinken, aber da hat sich einfach die Abkühlstung durchgesetzt, glaube ich. Aber bei keiner einzigen Pizza, die du bestellst, kriegst du keinen Käse. Das gibt's nicht. Egal welche Pizza du in der Pizzerie bestellst, du kriegst immer Käse, außer du sagst, besondere jetzt explizit ohne Käse. Das gehört immer dazu. Es ist immer die Basis. Es, ich, ich, ich finde es erstaunlich, dass man sich da nicht geeinigt hat. Also ich finde, da müssen sich mal diverse Pizzerien zusammensetzen, ob Käse dazu gehört oder nicht oder ob Käse nochmal bei Hawaii obendrauf gehört, weil ich fand's nicht gut, dass da nochmal extra Käse drüben ist, weil im Endeffekt, ich hab ja dann Doppelkäse, Hawaii, äh, Schinken, Ananas und dieses Gleichgewicht muss gewahrt werden und also es ergibt für mich überhaupt keinen Sinn bei etwas, was als Triangel, als Triade funktioniert. Das ist so eine Krebs. Nein, Stefan, mir geht's gut mir geht's gut, nein, mir geht's gut, etwas, das als Triade funktioniert, zu sagen, ah, da sind jetzt Doppelkäse drauf, weil am Ende, dann müsstest du ja entweder noch mehr schinken und noch mehr Ananas drauf tun und es ist ja kein Käse drauf tun, weil es ist ja eine Harmonie aus drei Teilen. In seinem Kopf vorgedrungen. Ich will nicht Käse doppelt Käse haben. Überall im Hirn. Weil dann habe ich ja am Ende viel zu viel Käse. Was spricht zu uns? Es muss gleichmässig sein. Oder Florentin. Es muss gleichmässig sein. Ist das noch sein Charakter? Oder der Döner. Oder was redet der Döner gerade. Also ganz ehrlich, es tut mir sehr leid. Ich finde es Bullshit, weil ich habe eine Pizza gegessen, da war viel zu viel Käse drauf. Und es hat einfach nicht mehr gesehen. Ja, hey, hey, hey, hey, ich weiß, vielleicht auch so Hermonhaushalt bei dir durcheinander oder so. Hey, ich würde sagen, also erstmal entschuldigen wir uns jetzt bei Italien und bei Italien. Und bei Italien. Und bei der Türkei am besten auch. Türkei auch, weil wir wollen uns entschuldigen, weil es heute ein bisschen zu hitzig über eure kulturell in euch drin, mit euch verbundenen Gerichte gesprochen. Dann möchte ich mich bei den Zuhörern und Zuhörern entschuldigen. Sorry, dass wir heute so ein bisschen emotional wurden und uns gestritten haben. Das wie, glaube ich, Eltern beim Streiten zuzuhören, zuzugucken, ist nicht so toll, so ist es nicht schön. Ich habe vielleicht eure Kultur über Bord geworfen, ich möchte sie gerne mit einem herzlichen Rettungsring, mit einem her herzlichen Kescher wieder zurückholen, an Bord. Drum friemeln. Niemand muss hier frieren. Wenn ich so einen toten Fisch aus dem Aquarium geholt habe, wenn man dann so, und dann kriegt man nie den ganzen toten Fisch in den Kescher. Dann zieht man den an der ganzen Aquariumscheibe, zieht man den an diesem toten Fisch dann so hoch. So zieht ihr euch raus. Ich habe frittierte Fischkräten, habe ich ich gesehen als Gericht, dass jemand so einen kleinen Sardinenfisch und komplett mit so einer Bürste abrupft, so dass nur noch die Gräten übrig bleiben und die werden frittiert. Frito. Es gibt so einen Kanal, der so super fünf Sterne Küche, super krasse Küche macht, der ist aber komplett auf Italienisch. Ich schaue trotzdem hier das Video, wo ich kein Wort verstehe, einfach weil es so exotisch ist und die dann tatsächlich, ich weiss nicht, ob man es auch isst, oder ob die Idee nur ist, dass es dann halt rotierte Gräte, dass es irgendwie dann cool aussieht, weil es dann auch so steif wird.
Ich möchte nur ganz kurz sagen, weil jetzt vielleicht auch viele rotieren, gerade zum Thema Döner-Teile, wie gross müssen die Einzelteile sein.
Ich erinnere mich einfach nur an ein prägendes Ereignis aus meiner Jugend, als ich Colorado Mini gesehen habe. Die Colorado Haribo Tüte, die als Mini nochmal. Und es ist für mich einfach ein Licht aufgegangen, dass ich gesagt habe, ja klar, natürlich, vielleicht muss es in anderen Grössen stattfinden. Weil wir kennen es bei Haribo, wo eigentlich auch immer die kleinen Gummibärchen geiler sind als die grossen. Und da denke ich nochmal an den Döner zurück. Ist es wirklich die beste Größe? Hat nicht die Technik da einen Fortschritt gemacht, dass wir in diesen Abfräs-Automaten da vielleicht eine andere Größe machen, dass alles eine Einheitsgröße kriegt? Ein Quadratzentimeter Salat, ein Quadratzentimeter Tomate. Ich finde das ja super, die Ratio zwischen Brot, Salat, Soße und Fleisch. Das ist ein ganz feines Feind. Ich finde das die perfekte Proportion. Und ich finde, man sollte nicht rumdoktern. Und da habe ich jetzt schon Angst, dass ein Brot so gross ist, dass du es aufschneiden kannst und was reinmachen kannst. Das suggeriert ja auch schon eine gewisse Größe. Ja, ja. Und dann hast du nachher zu viel Brot mit einem kleinen Minidöner. Ich finde auch Burger, da gibt es ja kleine Burger.
Gibt es manchmal in Slider. Wenn wir über Essen reden, haben wir beide irgendwie so feuchte Münder. Merkst du das? Und sabbern einfach die ganze Zeit. Es gibt so Slicer, genau, in den USA. Slicer. Dann kriegst du drei, wie viel? Slider. Slider. Drei verschiedene hast du dann auf dem Teller stehen und die sind klein und süss. Aber ich finde das nicht perfekt. Es ist nicht die perfekte Form. Nee, ich glaube, am Ende tages werden wir auch einfach akzeptieren müssen dass der dürüm die überlegene form ist die rolle aber das ist natürlich schlechtere brot ja auch gut vorstellen absolut ich könnte mir auch vorstellen dass in zehn jahren niemand mehr über döner kebab taschen spricht sondern der dürüm komplett war so lange beim dürüm und jetzt bin ich wieder beim dünner tasche ich bin froh dazu sein und ich brauche es nicht von dir jetzt zu hören, dass es die überlegendere Botform ist. Deswegen sorry, dass wir uns heute so angeschrien haben. Wir werden in den nächsten Folgen wieder harmonischer sein. Da reden wir über Themen, die wir beide gleich sehen. Keine Ahnung, irgendwas Unverfängliches. Also Wassereis oder so, wo man oder Politik. Ja, genau, Politik. Genau, Migrationspolitik, also was jetzt, was zu tun ist. Ja, genau, so Klimapolitik oder Wirtschaftspolitik. Oder Fussball. Ja, oder so Wirtschaftspolitik, so Abhängigkeit. Schuldenbremse, ja oder nein. So Saudi-Arabien oder so, was so Benzin angeht und so was. Genau, wie viel Einfluss hat China auf die deutsche Wirtschaft? Weil da gibt es, glaube ich, keine Reibungsmöglichkeiten. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Genau. Cool, alles klar. Dann können wir vielleicht einfach auch was aufbauen. Wir bauen was auf. Einfach vielleicht so eine Art Abenteuerspielplatz, den wir bereitstellen, wo Leute Podcasts aufnehmen können zum Beispiel. Das Deutsche Podcast Festival, wo wir einfach ein Mikrofon aufstellen, das 24-7 sendet und jeder kann sich hinsetzen. Und wenn jemand gerade schon podcastet und jemand anders möchte ran, dann legt man so ein wir können vielleicht so einen Stein bemalen dass wir so einen Stein nehmen und den so mit Farbe bemalen vielleicht mit verschiedenen Farben so dass man zeigen kann, ah ich will jetzt sofort rein, rot, ah ich würde in zehn Minuten nochmal kommen, blau ich fände die Vorstellung ganz gut, dieses Podcast-Vestival ich glaube es wird wie dieses Portal, was in, was New York mit Dublin verbunden hat was man ja fußt,aden hat, so eine Kunstinstallation. Ja, stimmt, was war das denn nochmal? Es war jetzt neulich, da wurde so ein Portal auf den Times Square gestellt und irgendwie in Dublin. Das war dann so ein großes Portal, wo man dann die andere Stadt live sehen konnte. Da haben sie so Flashmops und das war irgendwie süss und Leute haben getanzt und irgendwann wurde es obszön und schlimm und es wurde abgebrochen. Und genau so stelle ich mir das vor, unser 24-7-Livestream.
Das in einem Museum? Also im Museum hast du einen Raum mit einer Leinwand und siehst ein anderes Museum in Dublin. Oder in MoMA, genau. Und dann so wie so ein Bild, das du anstattest und du siehst Leute, die da so rumlaufen. Aber du musst auch ... Mit ihren Rucksäcken vorne. Oh, und dann stehen so zwei Tische mit Telefonen. Bei jeweiligen ... Also, ich glaube, einer ist cleaner. Ein Tisch mit einem Telefon und in Dublin steht auch ein Tisch mit einem Telefon. Und dann siehst du, in Dublin sitzt gerade jemand an einem Telefontisch und der Tisch bei mir ist noch frei, ich könnte mich da jetzt hinsetzen, um mit dem zu reden. Super. Und dann sagst du Hello Guy und dann kannst du obszöne Sachen reden. Wird abgebrochen nach 20 Minuten, alles klar. Sofort abgebrochen und es wird alles wieder gelöscht und abgehangen. Leider ist die Menschheit einfach verroht und wir können alle guten Ideen werden kaputt gemacht. Es ist wie diese Lehrer, die ja so bei Klassenfahrten immer gesagt haben, ja dann können wir es halt nicht mehr machen. Wenn ihr jetzt, wenn ihr mit den Spielsachen, dem Fußball, den ich euch stelle, so hinlege, dann können wir es halt nicht mehr machen.
Ja, wenn die komplette Brause alle auf einmal dem armen Jonathan in die Nase schiebt, dann gibt es jetzt halt keine Brause mehr. Ja, wenn ihr alle den Mittelfinger zeigt nach Dublin, dann können wir sowas wie dem Portal halt nicht mehr machen.
Wenn ihr die Hose runterzieht nach Dublin, dann geht das halt nicht mehr.
Ja, genau. So,
gut, dann schalten wir jetzt ab.
Genau so wird es dann sein. Tschüss Dublin. Wenn ihr nur obszöne
Sachen ins Telefon sagt, dann können wir sowas mit dem Telefon
halt nicht mehr machen.
Dem extra ein Kabel gelegt hier von Köln nach Dublin,
dann können wir es jetzt halt nicht mehr machen. Genau, das ist der Satz
und der ist sehr gut übertragbar auf die ganze
Menschheit. Ja, dann
beenden wir den Podcast an dieser Stelle für diese Woche. Wir wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz tolle Woche. Wir haben eine Zeit. Geniesst verschiedene kulinarische Kulturen, aber denkt auch darüber nach, wie man es verbessern könnte. Tradition ist nicht gut. Wenn ihr hört, wenn das einzige Argument ist, das haben wir immer schon so gemacht, dann gilt es, an den Grundfesten zu rütteln und zu schauen, was kriegen wir besser hin.
Tradition ist das Weitergeben der Flamme, nicht der Asche.
Aber Hawaii steht stets für Käse, Schinken und Nanas.
Tschüss, macht's gut wie immer!